klimawandel immer mehr menschen
verstehen
es ist jetzt allerhöchste eisenbahn
überall fordern schüler um studierende
eine nachhaltigere klimaschutzpolitik
wir müssen die erderwärmung aufhalten
klar nur wie nur noch fahrradfahren
vegan werden bäume pflanzen die
schlechte nachricht ist das reicht alles
nicht wir brauchen einen viel größeren
plan die gute nachricht wir haben den
plan und zwar einen wirklich guten
wissenschaftlichen plan den vor allem
die bundesregierung dringend höheren
musst du leider interessiert sich kein
politiker für youtube seite natürlich
visus involviert ich brauche deine hilfe
kannst du was für mich aufnehmen ok also
leuchtmann
hallo liebe politiker ich bin der mit
den blauen haaren erinnert jetzt hört
mal der mai zu weil das wichtig aber
nicht nur politiker sollten hier genau
zuhören jeder einzelne von euch spielt
hier eine sehr wichtige rolle
dazu komme ich auch gleich noch aber
konnte ich erst mal ein t macht es euch
gemütlich wir steigen jetzt zusammen
durch freunde der sonne holt eure
kalender und markiert euch den
zwanzigster september passieren nämlich
zwei wichtige sachen erstens der dritte
globale klima streik findet statt
überall auf der welt und in vielen
deutschen städten werden die leute auf
die straße gehen zweitens in berlin wird
sich das klima kabinett der
bundesregierung zusammen setzen um
konkrete klimaschutzmaßnahmen zu
beschließen deswegen knüpfen wir uns in
diesem video die zwei großen fragen vor
erstens was kann ich persönlich gegen
den klimawandel tun
und zweitens was kann die politik gegen
den klimawandel tun oder anders gesagt
was muss jetzt getan werden wir fangen
mit der politik an hier ist das
inhaltsverzeichnis für dieses video in
der video beschreibung findet ihr auch
die timecode links aber bitte schaut
euch das ganze video an denn es lohnt
sich wirklich die verschiedenen aspekte
auch alle zu verstehen kapitel eins was
muss die politik gegen den klimawandel
tun
bis auf ein paar wissenschafts
verweigerer sind sich unsere politiker
einig dass man auf die klimaforscher
hören muss und irgend etwas gegen den
klimawandel tun muss nur wie dieses
irgendetwas genau aussieht darüber ist
man sich nicht einig klima schützen
nicht klar
nur zu welchem preis geht das auf kosten
der sozialen gerechtigkeit auf kosten
von arbeitsplätzen auf kosten der
wirtschaft also über diese abwägung
streitet man sich nur deswegen was sagt
eigentlich die wissenschaft hierzu lars
und ich haben in den letzten wochen mit
vielen experten gesprochen mit
verschiedensten backgrounds sie waren
sich über fünf sachen einig jetzt gut zu
meinem ersten brauchen eine co2 die
preise fangen wir von vorne an was ist
denn die idee hinter so einer co2
bepreisung eins ist klar wir können es
uns nicht mehr leisten so weiterzuleben
wie momentan und jetzt panik wir können
es uns nicht leisten ist aber natürlich
sehr vage ein co2 preis sorgt dafür dass
wir tatsächlich finanziell sehen was wir
uns denn leisten können und was eben
auch nicht mehr
der co2 preis übersetzt unsere unsere
ökologischen ambitionen wir wollen das
klima schützen übersetzten co2 preis für
einen konsumenten und für eine firma und
für eine bank übersetztes in konkrete
ökonomische entscheidung das ist ottmar
edenhofer erst wirtschaftsprofessor und
leiter des potsdam-institut für
klimafolgenforschung er zusammen mit dem
sachverständigenrat der
wirtschaftsweisen der bundeskanzlerin
dieses sondergutachten vorgelegt hier
wird wissenschaftlich analysiert welche
klima politik jetzt gefragt ist wenn sie
den supermarkt gehen und einkaufen sie
können gar nicht überblicken was der co2
gehalt als der produkte ist es ist
unmöglich sie können vielleicht beim
anderen produkten sehen also mango an
weihnachten dass das vielleicht bisher
co2 intensiv ist aber sie können das
unmöglich bei allen produkten zählt das
heißt das wenn wir co2 bepreisung hätten
dann würden die preise im supermarkt
auch in co2 gehalt reflektieren und dann
würden wir an der kasse würden wir dann
eben
weniger bezahlen wenn wir co2
freundlicher eingekaufte wir übersetzen
gewissermaßen klimaschädlichkeit in geld
damit wir das konkreter verstehen und
angehen können wie genauso so eine co2
bepreisung aussehen es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten wie man einen co2 preisen
führen kann gehen wir beides kurz durch
erstens emissionshandel beim
emissionshandel liegt die regierung eine
gewisse menge co2 fest die in einem jahr
ausgestoßen werden darf also ein festes
co2 budget das nicht überschritten
werden darf
und dieses budget wird dann aufgeteilt
unter den unternehmen die co2 ausstoßen
die müssen nämlich um das zu tun sich
erstmal ausstoß rechte erwerben also
anteile an diesem budget sogenannte
zertifikate emissionshandel heißt das
ganze weil diese zertifikate jetzt
untereinander gehandelt werden können
wenn jetzt ein unternehmen erfolgreich
co2 reduziert so sehr dass es weniger
co2 ausstößt als es sich ursprünglich
eingekauft hat dann kann es die
überschüssigen zertifikate wieder
verkaufen und andersrum wenn jetzt
unternehmen mehr co2 ausstößt als es
sich ursprünglich eingekauft hat da
musste sich dafür diese zusätzlichen
zertifikate einkaufen und der preis der
zertifikate richtet sich nach dem markt
also nach angebot und nachfrage
das gesamt co2 budget wird mit den
jahren immer kleiner weil wir immer mehr
emissionen einsparen müssen
dadurch wird der co2 preis immer höher
die anreize emissionen zu sparen werden
also immer stärker zweitens co2 steuer
oder co2 abgabe bei dieser methode wird
von der regierung nicht das gesamtbudget
festgelegt sondern ein preis für co2
also ein preis pro tonne co2
man nimmt nämlich schlicht und einfach
kohle öl und gas von kohle öl und gas
erkennt man sehr genau dem co2 gehalt
und wenn wir zb importieren dann würde
man hier einfach eine steuerliche
auswirkung hat ein emissionshandel
eine co2 steuer auf die verbraucher also
steuer und emissionshandel wirken auf
eine ganz ähnliche weise am ende des
tages müssen wir die konsumenten
bezahlen denn für ein unternehmen co2
ausstoß teurer wird denn werden
natürlich auch die produkte teurer die
so entsteht je nach produkt wird dieser
co2 aufpreis nicht unbedingt stark ins
gewicht fällt der preis irgend eines
produktes setzt sich aus verschiedensten
aspekten zusammen nicht selten zahlen
der einfachen aufpreis allein für ein
logo oder für eine marke oder sondern
auch ford t shirt macht ein co2 preis
auch keinen unterschied mehr
aber bei produkten wie benzin oder
heizöl schon das ist jetzt endlich auch
der springende punkt nämlich das co2
ausstoß immer teurer und unattraktiver
wird das ganze ist also ein
marktwirtschaftlicher lösungsansatz für
unternehmen entsteht der anreiz co2
emissionen zu reduzieren
wer mehr co2 einspart kann günstiger
produzieren
und wer günstiger produziert hat einen
marktvorteil bevor wir gleich noch
genauer darauf eingehen was das ganze
ist für uns verbraucher bedeutet gibt es
doch eine sache die manche gar nicht auf
dem schirm haben nämlich wir haben in
manchen bereichen bereits eine co2
preise
wir haben nämlich seit 2005 einen
eu-weiten emissionshandel allerdings nur
in den sektoren stromerzeugung und
energieintensive industrie wie zum
beispiel die produktion von eisen zement
und papier und seit 2012 auch für den
luftverkehr
diesen sektoren machen zusammen etwa 45
prozent der eu weiten co2 emissionen aus
bei der stromerzeugung hat sich eu weit
und auch bei uns in deutschland schon
einiges getan
der anteil erneuerbarer energien ist auf
40 prozent gestiegen doch das reicht bei
weitem nicht wenn wir unsere klimaziele
für 2030 erreichen wollen die ziele für
2020 werden wir sicher verfehlen beim
bisherigen eu emissionshandel waren
erstens die effektiven co2 preise lange
viel zu niedrig um irgendeinen effekt zu
haben und zweitens fielen bei der ganzen
co2 bepreisung bisher ganz wichtige
sektoren unter anderem verkehr und
gebäude also hauptsächlich heizung das
heißt bei der aktuellen debatte um die
co2 preise
geht es nicht etwa um ein völlig neues
konzept sondern eigentlich nur um eine
ausweitung der derzeitigen und co2
preise und die forderung wir brauchen
eine co2 bepreisung heißt also
gleichzeitig wir brauchen eine
umfassende co2 bepreisung um unsere
klimaziele zu erreichen und wie man das
jetzt geschickt und besonders schnell
und gut hinbekommt also über einen
emissionshandel einen erweiterten oder
mit co2 steuer
darüber wird noch diskutiert da gibt es
verschiedene vor nachteile wenn ihr euch
interessieren haben wir der weitere
infos in der video beschreibung verliebt
im augenblick zb in deutschland mit der
diskussion gibt es viele menschen die
jetzt in der regierungskoalition sagen
wir wollen keine steuererhöhungen
deswegen emissionshandel lieber wobei
man nicht vergessen dass steuer und
emissionshandel wirken auf eine ganz
ähnliche weise hat wir haben in einem
großen gutachten für die bundesregierung
gesagt man kann beides machen
emissionshandel und steuer
es ist richtig dass die steuer
vielleicht schneller geht aber man kann
auch den emissionshandel so ausgestalten
dass das sehr sehr schnell gehen kann
das sind dann viele technische details
aber ich glaube nicht dass man wegen
steuer oder emissionshandel ein
glaubenskrieg führen sollte sondern man
sollte sich doch pragmatisch verhalten
durch aber wir die verbraucher und
bürger fragen uns jetzt natürlich ist so
ein co2 preis überhaupt ja klar der
grundgedanke ist natürlich wären schaden
anrichtet der der muss dafür zahlen
das ist so ein fundamentales prinzip in
allen kulturen problem eine co2
bepreisung trifft vor allem
niedrigverdiener obwohl sie im schnitt
klimafreundlicher leben wenn ich als
niedrigverdiener zum beispiel als
ungelernte kassiererin in einem
supermarkt in einer sehr kleinen wohnung
lebe und ein kleines auto fahre oder gar
kein auto habe dann verbrauche ich zwar
absolut gesehen wenig energie und
trotzdem nimmt diese energie einen
relativ großen anteil seines gehalts ein
nämlich im schnitt über 4 prozent auf
der anderen seite hat die regional
verkaufsleiterin
der selben supermarkt kette und fällt
das haus und führten schlitten gehört zu
den top verdienern gibt aber nur rund
zweieinhalb prozent ihres gehaltes für
energie aus hinzu kommt wenn ich genug
verdiene kann ich in ein effizienteres
auto oder in eine besser wärmegedämmte
wohnung investieren um dann so wieder
co2 kosten zu sparen
aber dieses upgrade muss ich mir auch
erst mal leisten können das ist ein
luxus die natürlich nicht jeder hat wenn
man gerade so über die runden kommt dann
ist es nur versteht nicht wenn man eine
hören von lebenshaltungskosten scheiße
findet das bekam frankreichs regierung
zu spüren als sie eine co2 steuer viel
fossile energieträger einführte mit
einer steuer die an der zapfsäule wirkt
hat in frankreich der präsident seine
bürger gegen sich aufgebracht in paris
demonstrieren heute wieder anhänger der
protestbewegung gelb westen bin 70 jahre
alt und das ist meine erste
demonstration alles ist gestiegen die
preise für benzin für gas und für strom
mir fehlen im monat 200 euro aber meine
rente ist nur um drei euro gestiegen wo
soll das hingehen ich habe 42 jahre lang
gearbeitet
am ende des monats reicht das geld nicht
wir kriegen unsere kinder nicht mehr
sagt finden sie das normal und hier
kommen wir zum zweiten punkt über den
sich die wissenschaftlichen experten
einig sind jetzt gut zu die co2
betreuung muss sozial gerecht seien und
zum glück gibt es ja auch möglichkeiten
gerecht zu gestalten das ist übrigens
klaus vom kanal zur energiewende
nachhaltigkeit er macht extrem coole
videos zu energiewende nachhaltigkeit
und hat sich mit dem thema schon
beschäftigt die erste möglichkeit wäre
eine art klima dividende
so macht es die schweiz zum beispiel mit
ihrer lenkungsabgabe auf brennstoffe
normale steuer landet ihr einfach nur
beim start aber in diesem fall darf der
staat das geld nicht einfach verhalten
sondern muss es an alle bürger
gleichmäßig wieder auszahlen wie eine
dividende eben jeder bekommt den
gleichen betrag zurück wichtig an der
sache ist dass man wenn man das
zurückerstattet an die haushalte muss
man das einfach machen das geht nur
durch mehr einfache regel wenn man also
jetzt prüfen müsste ob das die
bedürftigkeit gewährleistet ist dann
wird das ein bürokrat
das monster deswegen haben wir
vorgeschlagen man nimmt einfach die
gesamtsumme teilt die durch die anzahl
der bürger und gibt jedem pro kopf den
gleichen anteil ihr könnt euch das
ungefähr so vorstellen
jeder von uns verursacht her
unterschiedlich viel co2 im jahr
aber im durchschnitt sind wir in
deutschland bei um die zehn tonnen pro
kopf und das bedeutet jeder bekäme erst
mal den preis für diese zehn tonnen co2
im jahr zurück wer selbst mehr ausstößt
indem er besonders dickes auto fährt
besonders oft fliegt und so weiter der
zahlt natürlich mehr drauf als er zurück
bekommt ganz nach dem verursacherprinzip
ist ja irgendwie sinn der sache mehr
dagegen aber besonders klimafreundlich
lebt kommt in der regel bei einem plus
haus denn viel weniger bezahlt bekommt
aber genauso viel zurück die alle
anderen und so eine klima dividende
hätte ein paar interessante effekte
gerade einkommensschwache haushalte
würden im normalfall als gewinner
dastehen eben weil sie durch ihren
sparsamen lebensstil relativ wenig co2
verursachen dann selbst einen
finanziellen anreiz klimafreundlich zu
leben wie geil ist das denn bisher war
das oft teurer und drittens wenn es sich
lohnt unter dem durchschnitt zu legen
dann sinkt auf dauer ja der durchschnitt
selbst dass wenn ich schon faszinierend
und so eine tina dividende ist sowohl
bei einer co2 steuer als auch bei einem
emissionshandel möglich in beiden fällen
werden die einnahmen wieder
zurückgezahlt in dem einen fall werden
steuereinnahmen und einem anderen fall
zins versteigerungserlöse es ist es
eigentlich im kern immer der gleiche
mechanismus eine andere möglichkeit der
stadt eine auszahlung wäre es einfach
andere steuern zu senken so wird es zum
beispiel in schweden gemacht und bei uns
könnte man die stromsteuer senken warum
die stromsteuer weil die
einkommensschwachen haushalte
überproportional viel für strom ausgeben
und wenn sie dann entlastet werden
dann kann man in sozial ungerechten
effekt des co2 preise kompensieren und
ich sag mal generell steuern auf
klimafreundliche alternativen wie bahn
fahren zum beispiel noch damit würde man
insbesondere niedrigverdiener entlasten
bei der eben einen größeren anteil ihres
gehalts für strom werden mobilität
ausgeht natürlich wird man nie
ausschließen können dass es nicht herr
man muss mit solchen härtefällen umgehen
deswegen haben wir auch vorgeschlagen
dass man so ein härtefallfonds
einrichtet um leute die dann eben auf
dem land leben überhaupt keine
infrastruktur haben usw
dass die dann entlastet werden
zusammengefasst eine co2 bepreisung kann
durchaus sozial gerecht kompensiert
werden insofern ist das wort co2 steuer
auch gar nicht unbedingt passend werden
diese steuer an eine klima dividende
geknüpft ist doch da gibt es immer noch
gegenwind aus der industrie und auch von
manchen politikern die sagen das kostet
arbeitsplätze das schadet der wirtschaft
lieber nicht einführen sondern
stattdessen nur auf neue technologien
setzen doch die wissenschaft sei etwas
anderes jetzt gut zu hören
drittens eine co2 bepreisung schadet
nicht der wirtschaft im gegenteil
also wir wissen dass der ungebremste
klimawandel höhere ökonomische schäden
anrichtet als das was wir heute an
kosten aufwenden müssen um die
emissionen zu reduzieren also vor dem
hintergrund ist klimapolitik ökonomisch
sinnvoll ist schon einen ökonomischen
folgeschäden hinter zukunft gehört aber
was wir in deutschland jetzt brav
emissionen spart während andere länder
einfach fröhlich weiter co2 ausstoßen
die angst vor solchen trittbrettfahrern
kann dazu führen dass niemand was machen
möchte
dieses problem haben wir schon in diesem
video über spieltheorie besprochen
klar das ist eine riesenherausforderung
klimaschutz funktioniert nur global eine
gefahr die die wirtschaft sieht das
ganze unternehmen abwandern in andere
länder weil wir klimapolitik betreiben
und anderes nicht betreiben die gefahr
kommen nur kommen wenn man dann co2
preise in allen ländern einführen
merkel am 21 september auch zum
un-klimagipfel in new york auch der
ganze serien von kreaturen weg und so
weiter unsere geschichte hat sehr
mehrfach gezeigt dass es möglich ist
solche trittbrettfahrer fallen zu
überwinden
zum beispiel der erfolgreiche weltweite
ausstieg aus den
fluorchlorkohlenwasserstoffen der
ursache für das ozonloch außerdem wenn
andere länder besser darin
anreize zu schaffen um zukünftige
emissionsärmere technologien zu
entwickeln
dann werden diese länder den
zukunftsmarkt dominieren ok heißt es
jetzt eine co2 bepreisung ist die lösung
gegen den klimawandel die wissenschaft
sagt nein
jetzt gibt es eine co2 bepreisung
alleine reicht nicht aus es ist ja klar
wenn ich co2 sparen möchte muss ich co2
ärmere alternativen zur verfügung haben
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel öfter
fahrrad statt auto fahren möchte
dann brauche ich auch eine entsprechende
verkehrsführung mit der ich von a nach b
kommen ohne mein leben zu riskieren
in essen fahren die leute immer mehr
fahrrad aber es steigt die zahl der
fahrradunfälle wenn sie den
deutschlandverkehr tatsächlich mehr auf
die straße bringen wollen dann brauchen
sie auch entsprechend mehr verkehrsraum
war für das kann ja nicht sein dass
jetzt bei den wenigen verkehrsflächen
die dafür zur verfügung stehen sich
hinterher der ganze radfahrverkehr
knubbelt und ab und zu verteilen lang
aber auf drei spuren die da noch
ausgebaut sind
um das mal extrem zusammen ist muss
umgedacht werden es müssen mehr
verkehrsräume tatsächlich dem radfahrer
zur verfügung gestellt werden klar wenn
ich mal öffnet den bus nehmen möchte
muss sich erstmal einen bus in der nähe
haben der mich dahin bringt wo ich hin
möchte emissionsarme alternativen
schaffen muss also aktiv gefördert
werden erreicht der co2 preis alleine
noch nicht wir brauchen investitionen
und subventionen in bereichen wie
öffentliche nahverkehr oder wärmenetze
wir brauchen auch ganz neue
technologische innovationen
revolutionäre ideen wie zum beispiel
eine klimaneutrale stahlerzeugung für
solche enormen sprünge muss forschung
und entwicklung ordentlich gefördert
werden aber fällt nicht darauf rein
wenn leute behauptet dass forschung und
innovation uns alle retten werden nein
forschung und innovation alleine reicht
genauso wenig aus wie die co2 bepreisung
allein weil wir zwar mit effizienteren
autos fahren aber wir waren eben auch
mehr
die wohnungen sind besser gedämmt aber
haben eben auch größere wohnungen dh der
wissenschaftliche rat der experten an
die politik ist erstens wir brauchen
eine co2 bepreisung weil sie eine
wirkungsvolle und wirtschaftliche
maßnahmen gegen den klimawandel ist
zweitens die co2 bepreisung muss sozial
gerecht
stichwort kompensation zum beispiel
klima dividende und drittens sie muss
durch zusatzmaßnahmen begleitet werden
förderung von emissionsarmen
alternativen neuer technologien und
weitere gesetzliche standards können
auch sinnvoll sein denn dann gibt es
natürlich auch manchmal bereiche wo
konsumenten in ihren kaufentscheidungen
mit ganz rational sind also zum beispiel
niemand ein auto kauft beim rechnet
sofort wie viel ist jetzt meine co2
ersparnis bei konstanz sehr sinnvoll
sein dass man mit technologie standards
arbeitet und bei noch etwas sind sich
die experten einig und das ist jetzt
sehr wichtig jetzt gut zu hören nur
politische maßnahmen können große
veränderungen bringen ohne diese
politischen maßnahmen ohne diese großen
kollektiven veränderungen ist alles was
wir so alles einzelpersonen machen her
radfahren weniger fleisch essen wie auch
immer das alles nur keine panik das
alles auf die individuen auf uns
einzelne ob gelastet abgelagert wird und
abgewälzt wird dann passiert doch das
was wir schon wissen
einige werden das tun andere werden
nichts tun deswegen diesen co2 preis so
wichtig weil erst durch den co2 preis
addieren sich die individuellen
anstrengungen aller auf aber heißt das
jetzt dass ich als einzelperson gar
nichts tun kann
nein ganz im gegenteil kapitel 2 was
kann ich als einzelperson gegen den
klimawandel tun
es gibt zwei sehr wichtige dinge die
jeder einzelne von uns tun kann oder
sogar tun muss erstens hört auf mit
scheinargumenten die klimadebatte ist
verpestet durch unlogische
scheinargumente die sowohl uns als auch
die politiker davon abhalten sind voll
zu handeln ein häufiges problem ist
sowas hier doppelmoral aller luisa
neubauer regierung und politiker für
angeblich fehlendes engagement beim
klimaschutz attackieren aber mit 23 mehr
kontinente bereits damals die meisten
deutschen und sie fliegt weiter aber nur
aus absoluter notwendigkeit glaubwürdig
hashtag vorbild das sind alles argumente
die verhindern sollen dass politiker
jetzt endlich ihre verantwortung wahr
dieses argument tiefes scheinargument
ist nichts weiter als ein atom bin im
moment das hatten wir auch hier schon
mal
es sollte keinen unterschied machen ob
ein argument auf einen neutralen blatt
papier geschrieben steht oder ob eine
person dieses argument vorträgt atom -
kurz für argumente um ihnen bezieht sich
auf ein argument das ich nicht auf den
streitpunkt bezieht sondern auf die
person mit der ich streite du brauchst
mir gar nichts zu den risiken von
alkohol erzählen so viel wie du läufst
kein argument gegen alkohol sollte
unabhängig sein von der person die
dieses argument vorträgt und wie sehr
solche argumente gerade bei umwelt
debatten schaden sehen wir in diesem
einfachen beispiel fall sagen wir hier
hier vorn ersten reihe der kraft hinter
spielt kevin du hast jetzt kennt den
halbmasken gelungen war geschmissen und
hat man ihn danach fragt sagt er habe
ich nicht gemacht habe
da haben wir klaus hoppe steht klaus
oder klaus und auf plastik nur in den
wald geschmissen dabei verkündet klaus
regelmäßig und öffentlich um geschützt
sei das allerwichtigste
sowas wird schlimmer kevin den lügner
oder klaus den häusern die mehrheit der
menschen findet fall b schlimmer als wir
hatten heuchler
wir verachten heuchler mehr als
glücklich lebe ich nicht dermassen auf
mich im wald oder die umwelt ich reg
mich vor allem darüber auf dass diese
pizza sich besser darstellt als er
eigentlich ist
während ich mich hier so lange breite
aufträge die plastik mit dem wald und
niemand interessiert und dass der platz
liegt mir wirklich interessiert das
sehen wir an falls sie da haben wir hier
jerome hat auf lassen wenn sie den wald
geschmissen und als man ihn fragt sagt
er ja habe ich gemacht
ich stehe dazu ich hab's nicht so mit
der umwelt und wie finden wir schon ganz
okay oder ich meine wenigsten ist
ehrlich ja natürlich ist warum ehrlich
an
sie ist dem wald doch scheißegal ob
darum ehrlich zu nicht fakt es da liegt
müll weil wir immer nur an uns selbst
denken finden wir den häusern am
schlimmsten
dann kommt der lügner und dann kommt der
ehrlich übeltäter aber wer wirklich an
den wald denken würden müssen wir es
genau andersrum sehen wir sollen klaus
das nervt dass du heute bist aber
wenigstens macht sich klaus prinzipiell
für umweltschutz laut kevin das zweite
und wohl dass du lügst aber wenigstens
scheint kevin zu wissen dass er etwas
falsch gemacht hat und warum hier die
einfach offen ehrlich zugibt auf den
wald zu schalten
zudem müssten wir eigentlich sagen [ __ ]
you grow scheinargumente wie atom einem
argument sind nichts als sinnlose
ablenkung vom eigentlichen problem und
werden nicht selten von leuten denen das
klima egal ist oder die wissenschaft
verweigern
ganz bewusst eingesetzt um abzulenken
fällt nicht darauf rein macht nicht mit
lasst uns bitte aufhören mit diesem
logischen schweiz zweitens an die
öffentlichkeit gehen es gibt immer mehr
menschen die zeigen dass ihm
nachhaltigkeit und umweltschutz wichtig
ist sei es indem sie es als influenza
vorleben oder indem sie bei future auf
die straße gehen und ich sage euch das
ist verdammt einflussreich in die
wenigsten politiker werden eine
entscheidung treffen von der sie glauben
dass sie bei ihren wählern unbeliebt ist
politikerleben von akzeptanz ihre
karrieren sind von beliebtheit abhängig
wenn politiker jetzt sehen dass menschen
zum beispiel freiwillig ihre autos
verzichten weniger fleisch essen bäume
pflanzen oder über den atlantik segeln
dann stärkt das klimafreundliche politik
den rücken und setzt gleichzeitig
diejenigen unter druck die vor den
warnungen der klimaforscher augen und
ohren verschließen
das verfügte hat enorm viel bewegt noch
vor einem jahr als ich über co2 preise
geredet haben alle gesagt oh co2
da kommen dann die gelben westen diese
in frankreich gibt auch in deutschland
durch reines for future sind die
parteien aufgewacht
alle parteien vor allem auch die
regierungsparteien die sagen wir müssen
was tun wir verstehen jetzt dass die
jungen leute sich das nimmer bieten
lassen dass die politik die man politik
einfach verschleppt gleichzeitig bewirkt
jede öffentliche aufmerksamkeit von
klimawandel leugnen und wissenschaft zu
verweigern
natürlich genau das gegenteil und obwohl
diese gruppe von menschen eigentlich
ziemlich kleines sind sie leider extrem
gut darin sehr laut und sichtbar zu sein
aber die vernunft hat auch eine stimme
und zwar eine viel größere dieter
sammelt sich am freitag den 20 september
auf den straßen deshalb freude der sonne
und dieses planeten schaut bitte in die
video beschreibung der erste link den er
dort findet zeigt euch die klima demos
in eurer nähe jeder von uns zählt dieses
video ist unser 500.000 abo special
wir wollten irgendwas besonderes zu
diesem anlass machen und das hier ist es
geworden halbe million ist voll die
unbegreifliche zahl ich kann nur vielen
dank sagen und viele kekse rausgeben an
alle die zuschauen und die
wissenschaftlichen spiel leben hier
kommt dir zu unseren bisherigen abos
patches besonders kann ich natürlich
unser 10.000 abo special empfehlen und
hier kommt ihr zum kanal von klaus mit
den themen energiewende nachhaltigkeit
er macht so geile videos er hat viel
mehr als verdient und kekse also schaut
doch mal vorbei
wir sehen uns bleibt sicher